yeah I can see why people are taking
poor I think poor is a better overall
fighter strength of schedule is better
his wins at the highest level are better
I know Justin gaichi does well in the
chaos I know he's they say he's a change
fighter but I don't think he never shake
that it's in his DNA which is what makes
him great which makes him The Human
Highlight I do think we'll get a little
more grappling in this fight I think
poor is gonna initiate it Porey has a
significant advantage on the ground when
it comes to jiu jitsu it doesn't Boise
is a legit black belt on the ground to
support it does implement uh wrestling
more than just in gaichi but I do think
Dustin's gonna incorporate grappling
more especially if uh the light kicks
are success early on by just engaging I
think could negate that with takedowns
something from kicking get into the head
I would say I could see poor a winning
via submission
so I'll take for you